hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
dishonored okay I've decided that I'm
gonna play however I feel like playing
stupid I'm a murdering bastard right in
front of your face Oh whatever are
anyway so I'm gonna just play however I
feel like playing if I feel like killing
people like nude people I might just do
that
hello absolutely I'm going to have the
best time right he's an ass you're a
sham yes even the norwegians businessman
from up north who you see her you're
boring me what are you doing what nurse
[ __ ] dip I am a successful rich
Norwegian business mein my varied
interests were confined to her family Oh
very interesting I'm bored litters move
on well oh that does not look good I'm
supposing that will destroy me if I walk
through it's lady Boyle
hello madam what the hell should tonight
oh my goodness your mask is Lord Brisby
oh I guess I can drop the Norwegian
accent I know you all were thinking that
it's the best Norwegian accent you've
ever heard but it just I have to drop
that the act for our Lord Brisby here
what's up Lloyd Brisby
oh no I'll go around don't get out of my
way or anything what's up okay
oh whatever
that if you'll bring her to me unlock
you will never hear of her again uh-huh
there's a cellar directly below the
kitchen yeah we'd be there okay surely
it's better than seeing her killed
Oh we'll see about that Lydia forever
nobody knows what I was just thinking
about but I know and anybody who knows
knows so long as those who know knows I
know that I'll know that you guys know
anyway so I need to say you're not lady
Boyle but you got the same what you
changed
wait what I trust
yes I am the Norwegian businessman that
we all heard about what are you what are
you doing in the bathroom me yeah wait
boat in this whoops um I may have made a
mistake here cuz I'm not sure how to get
her out of here without being noticed
hmm no one's gonna notice this at all
give me what no it's this is normal oh
boy I screwed up is this even the real
lady Boyle Oh Jude Adam ass too maybe
that wasn't the best of ideas Master
Assassin
alright so apparently there's also more
than one lady Boyle how do I know which
ones Oh anything on here uh there was
another lady Boyle I saw right here what
oh I bet you of a real lady Boyle okay
so there are three lady Boyles one in
red one in black and one in white oh yes
I am
alright so I need to figure out a way to
find out which one's the real one this
looks nice yes what is your mask a
freaking whale deal I could offer you
the rumours say the boils practically
own yours
what if I said I could get you out of
the city away oh hello lady Boyle if
that's really you how do I figure out
which one's a real one hello again
mm-hmm there's another lady boil over
there they can all pass through that
gate I'm betting I'm guessing I am
cheerful ha stop saying I'm not cheerful
to be no way loyal mmm
the wall of light is a gift from the
Lord Regent designed to keep his good
friends safe aha don't you qualify hey
shut up you so it kill me is that what
you're saying damn it how do I figure
out which ones which I have a distinct
problem here if you want to be beaten go
right ahead oh you sisters in red Oh
my wife thinks we should sneak upstairs
to look for clues but I don't like the
looks of those guards uh-huh all right
I'm gonna go okay
please how about you shut up that's
quite a mess are you of course I am the
rich Norwegian businessman but there's
no country called Norway here [ __ ] you
know I'm not yet one lady Boyle in red
you you shut up maybe boil in black you
smell like the street shut up
enjoy the party Lydia Waverly ESMA why
read there has to be a clue upstairs
just of course okay I get it I got to
get upstairs but how
all right maybe there's a way outside it
to get upstairs it probably is us out I
love the quick load times on this okay
you're not talking to me all right let's
see here
hmm oh hello that looks like a way up
also whatever that building right yes
enjoy yourself inside I will whenever I
want to shut up no one's gonna see this
magic ooh
balls let me just put away my yeah Lord
Shaw why am I talking to the Lord Shaw
again walked up Oh am I dueling this guy
wait what gentleman acting for the
challenger wha Trevor Pendleton no
challenge parties what you will each
turn and proceed to the marked positions
and remain facing away from each other
as I count down from three you may then
turn and fire it on with it dude really
suck if I slow time down whoa hey whoa
what happened to my dueling pistol what
Oh what sorry the hard-headed go at it
uh whoops I done goofed stop right there
I done goofed
uh-huh uh-huh well boom haha and justice
has been served
whoops it's lucky we're in demand
I hear the Esther mots pay top coin no
use trying them tonight let's see if we
can find a little brandy wheels clean up
the mess maybe that was a mistake
I don't know but I think I may be able
to get in here here we go the ballroom
ah I bet I could have gotten to here
inside the other way couldn't I have yes
please I'm ravenous hello lady Boyle
mm-hmm they say Lydia's
uh-huh and Waverly's approved or is it
the other way around
uh-uh if only I could peek upstairs why
are you dusting that man step back sir
Oh what all right whatever you know you
know okay I got to get upstairs oh well
really oh really oh let's see here
what's down here then blood oh it's good
[Music]
can you get fat in this game I don't
even know bread so hungry with a jello
all right so anyway oh oh now that that
feast is over yeah so I'm tired yeah I
could take a nap I suppose servants
quarters I guess I'm stealing all the
servants money see um no wait what red
ropes no okay hello baby
we're all alone down here ah oh oh the
two of you Hey
ha ha ha so what's down here there's got
to be a way easy way to get upstairs
switch needed click click that's which
okay I guessing this is a storage area
but it doesn't look like there's any way
up looks like this just goes down oh
hello
oh ok I get it I get it sorry sorry
sorry sorry I got it yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's here unbreakable Thor basement
vault needed all right what if I bring
her the wrong him the wrong one how are
we gonna sneak her past these two maybe
I gotta get rid of these two first maybe
just maybe hello ma'am
nice day we're having here a cup gets
what to turn around nice day we're
having her oh I can drag him too sorry
go Betty boy No
what have I done oh she's still sleeping
no that poor lady oh my
ah where did God come from like a shadow
in the night nope didn't see it I think
I might us yeah oh okay you were just
you're just bashing up little rats there
sorry but I don't have any reason to not
kill you so oh that's a reason no one
Minds if I have my weapons out right
right lady what no no boom no you do
things no you didn't see you think I'm
gonna hit yeah yeah there we go
you did good you didn't see a thing you
didn't find anything
no one's down oh ho oh I might have
heard him what the hell are you doing
what the hell is that
oh my that cannot be right
oh that's that this is what the hell is
that what get going on oh whoops
we all good we good are we good are we
good I don't like that I'm gonna I'm
gonna load back up cuz I screwed the
pooch on that one like big time
seriously big time screwed that up so
these two are sleeping that one slightly
uh it's so freaky I could fix her but
yeah I don't feel like it alright so
that guy is now gone but that made ah
that's who set off the alarm all right
so you man why are there so many maids I
just got to take care of the maids no
don't go either don't go in there okay
good yeah yeah yeah yeah shut up why is
this not working
yeah oh you look so good uh no just
admiring here crouched down staring
right at your ass huh
there we go later we should meet for a
smoke
yeah later yeah later that's right sorry
okay you're on Costas unconscious uncut
is not dead am i some kind of weirdo
here I kind of look like a freak don't I
okay so now oh no you it's you yeah I
don't have any reservations about
killing you son I save keep your
distance
oh I'll keep my distance I mean your
neck
that's much quicker than making someone
fall unconscious that's quicker much
easier all right no one saw thing like a
shadow in a bunion I know that didn't
make sense whale oil tank whatever Nev
that okay I'm doing a terrible terrible
terrible job of getting upstairs no I
did a great job I'm upstairs I am now
trespassing I know I did a great job
great job there hams free I am upstairs
now now would you look at this
no one's up here a interesting I'll keep
my weapons out anybody in there oh yes
ah good thing I did that cuz otherwise I
would have had that be a problem okay
asthma boil tonight tonight tonight the
party's gonna be fabulous
I shall bed the first man to ask for it
Oh who is asthma what is she wearing
huh and the second after that I can take
off my mask and be the second guy ha ha
ha ha who where what what is she wearing
huh ha ha what's she wearing what's she
wearing
drink from the bathtub that seems a
little weird what's he wearing what is
he wearing
tell me please tell me I want to know I
want to know what's he wearing what you
wearing I want to know no no I want to
know ok anyway oh that guy's gone
I wonder where he went oh there he's
farther down the hall alrighty so the
Isle of Sark CONUS the hell was that all
about in whatever River cross blah
whatever ah woo who are you you look so
lovely
wha you should upgrade the staff I'll
upgrade something yeah
[ __ ] Hank you didn't see a thing like a
shadow in the night like a shadow in the
night I didn't mean to just like Jack
that painting although it's perfectly
acceptable you're over there eh
the two of you just partying out just
brewing out who is this something a boil
egg I don't like that it's a lot of you
but Jake nope didn't do you think cuz
you are now sleeping you're sleeping and
now you're saving what oh damn it damn
it damn it
ah fine okay you're dead now oh fudge
daughters punch how did I pick the wrong
frickin Oh Oh the wrong one
whatever don't matter I'm carrying on
because the key now to whatever
why didn't Waverly just tell me what
they were wearing
God said oh do be stupid mother hover oh
whatever
give me that key house is healthy girl
see as must set aside more than enough
spirits
ah so ESMA is his wife huh uh hi what no
wait no oh that's know as Waverly
Waverly's a girl's name no Waverly I
thought Waverly was the guy I'm so
confused I still don't know who anybody
is
and now they're dead guards just laying
out in the hall ones asleep to the other
dead Oh everybody's having a fun time
bill
or are those screams of terror this
still doesn't help me get across a hole
now anybody no good all right now whose
room is this
ah purple oh ho lacy things eh a clue
looking forward to the party fine young
musician harpsichord right Lydia right
then Oh Lydia like musicians maybe this
information can be used against her okay
ah cool uh all right uh uh basement
vault key got that little three costumes
for the party Paisley that can't be
there I'm sure you understand why I know
you're going to look lovely in black in
black the one in black is the one that
was the first one that I had
oh okay so Lydia is in black yeah scroll
wait no what okay eliminate lady Boyle
in the black dress which one was asthma
which one was asthma ha ha ha all right
so anyway I got the identity and now I
can make her sleep and go carrier down
into the yellow all right
Boyle pocket watch whatever and now I
can find a way I gotta find a way to get
her down into the dibs not a grenade a
grenade is not the answer this time most
of the time a grenade would be an answer
but not this time so here we go no Jenny
buddy dear no of course not cuz it's
just me all right now I just got to find
a way to get down
steers aha yeah hardly hardly I don't
know the first meaning of expensive am i
no longer okay good thank you now I just
got to get lady Boyle in black and some
how are you yes it is hey baby you want
to go upstairs
lady Boyle oh you're in the bathroom
again am I gonna sneak you in from them
all right I'll wait for you this time
lady Boyle no yo what hey how do you get
there hey lady Boyle hey oh yes
maybe I should get you a drink drink
anything else
maybe absolutely I do not get out of
here Asma shall we do Oh get out of here
Asma
all right whatever well what shall we do
nothing to say Oh God okay I'll play
your stupid hearts at court god there's
too many people in here
dang no you oh come on
white no no it's hard to think no one's
or anything get out of here get out of
here you're such an a-hole you're an
a-hole your nail didn't cost no nothing
nothing's happening nothing's happening
everything is fine everything is fine
and dandy no one saw anything okay all
right anyway yeah I was talked about to
seduce your wife bro but yeah I didn't
cuz that would have been wrong hey so
much stuff oh my god oh my ruin Arun oh
and I can failsafe
aw crap nope there we go
no one saw anything yeah Jesus yeah you
could have told me that she was in black
yeah yeah yeah no she won't
whole life no no yeah probably not till
hey if for the rest of her days and
you'll go off living in sadness and
sorrow
I am not shut up you're such a douche
that's more like it
oh now about a lady boil in the red
dress yeah oh wait is there more stuff
that I could do here
Samuels boat all right I gotta get
outside go to the sewers ah man I so
wanted to get with asthma I had an in I
could have been all up on that I could
have hit that yeah totes lame
totes bro totes mix croats bro could've
hit that bar I guess it's so sad okay
that wasn't heavy at all
no one gets he may know why is that tall
boy looking right in the river seriously
why is that Samuel has moved find him
past the canal gate okay then ah oh no
no don't don't don't kill me no dad no
time there we go
can't get me now oh I'm going the wrong
way
matters you know see a thing is stupid
ow and hurt you can't see a thing
how budge okay need to get some air get
some health and then scoop underneath
the waters
you heard me scoop dude do and scoop a
dupe again for now I'm good I can
breathe
dammit I know I know I need to get out
of the water I can get around this tall
boy if I just sneak
snake sneakiness you don't see a thing
okay cool and now I'm know you don't see
a thing
no damn it oh fudge ah you don't see a
thing oh no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no ways loose
and we are like vows oops what yeah
overall chaos low yeah oh yeah yeah and
I had fun
see that's what I want to do I want to
have fun in this game and see what
happens
you know that's all I want to do if it
turns out that that happens to be
murdering I have a sort of thing I don't
like to kill women in video games I
don't know what it is
I just don't so that's why I didn't kill
lady Boyle
I took the wine cellar oh I probably
shouldn't have killed his buddies yeah I
I would have killed them anyway
it's so pretty I still can't get over
how pretty this game is I mean just look
at it all flippin gorgeous nah anyway
debrief with Lord Pendleton I'm actually
curious why I had to have a duel with
that guy
either way I got a lot of money wait who
are you I trust you enjoyed
oh I did who are you again handle tune
is anxious to see you okay I think he is
taking his morning his morning
refreshment say hello I did now we've
done away with a woman and a noblewoman
at that okay bye
she helped the Lord Regent kill the
Empress uh-huh so I don't feel a thing
for her well she's not dead I heard you
upheld my name and a rather spectacular
stop yes I want to thank you for your
welcome this little item has been
helpful to my family over the
generations yes a rule more useful than
I ever will a rule is it a rune where is
it is it a rune yes I did but I fear
it's not over oh no have already cooked
up something more for you they would
like to see you now
and have locks chambers above the ball
you got it friend rude rude Oh God let's
see what can I do now
devouring swarm sounds diabolical
bloodthirsty yeah brutal melee
fatalities yes yes yeah yes oh I want to
do that order doing what a good that
will be helpful on a murder yes or no do
it okay I'm okay I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay
whoo I'm all right sorry about that
folks
went a little crazy well okay I could
get dark cruise dark Christian part two
oh man getting a little lightheaded
I haven't had anything to eat all day
today so I'm a little bit whew shouldn't
have gone excessive like that all right
what are you here for me time has come
the hard thing we have done everything
that you have done yeah it served to
make this moment possible Oh what moment
is this exposed yeah all things in place
to strike it here yeah right one you
mean my throne one beating heart is all
that's left of the forces that brought
this city to the brink of ruin
hey I'm simple wait a minute far from
easy the Lord Regents paranoia has
reached an all-time high weight loss of
the support of the overseers the
Parliament his financial base and his
lost Sokoloff made his security
technology right so a dunwall tower he
has consolidated every remaining loyal
man he knows something is coming he
knows you are coming mm-hmm everything
depends on him being correct right arrow
will help you prepare then Samuel will
take you close to the tower near the
water loss rah last time you were there
was the horrible day that all of this
started now you will go there and end it
good luck why did I suddenly stop
trusting either of you other than our
hopes are riding on you hmm
mister something smells fishy about this
I don't like the look of it I don't like
the look of any of this who wears this
go pump master hello baby oh oh I'll
have a better night oh I'll enjoy myself
over all right shut up God fine
all right so now we're away now I need
to talk with probably the lady what is
what's ur name you know my ward daughter
person hey hi hey where are ya right go
give me those
oooh what dirt what hello whoever you
are I must thank you for sparing at
least part of my family
we all have enemies certainly we boil
women in a way you've done me a favor so
you deserve a reward I passed this along
from one of my servants through another
I who knows another to one of yours
maybe we never cross paths again no my
love oh now I really love I'm not that
kind of guy yeah Oh what what what oh
like a boss a stealthy it in here and
then steal this key and got your key and
give me your stuff yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes shut up and yes girl all right
let's see here is the word crossing yeah
all right let's see bone term capacity
you why not I've got money I don't know
what you know I'm just gonna start
slapping on some upgrades here cuz I've
got a lot of coin and I need to do
something with it I think crossbow range
that sounds good
dink donk dink yep that sounds about
right
okay thank you I got you hello - goodbye
yah yah yah yah masquerade blah blah
blah gonna save blah blah get out of my
way I got stuff to do heard that sham
real
hello he's the Lord yeah about time we
took care of mine yeah last time yeah
why do everyone keep rubbing their face
like that alright let's go yeah I have a
bad feeling about this for some reason I
don't like the look of this I'm starting
to suspect that I may be playing into
the hands of some of stumpy and walleye
there
oh yeah I nicknamed the other guy
walleye of Oh last memories of dunwall
tower might not be good no not really
I'm okay with that
god I still can't get over the detail
just place Richard built himself quite a
place the top of the tower yeah I see
that now it's safe or something
uh-huh crazy ask me yeah not crazy
because it's a Master Assassin after his
control station uh-huh all right
whatever you say I trust you shut up I'm
gonna be fine you're gonna see your
Luffy oh oh oh like a boss oh oh so
great I'm so great oh wait what Oh
can I get up there
oh good Oh No all right No
so that's a no let's see here
is there any way wait maybe I can
upgrade in agility again Acrobat I know
I have those okay those are all equipped
anyway sorry sorry sorry sorry
agility oh I have one rune I need three
I should've gotten another rank of
agility now whatever it don't matter
yeah oh no this is the wrong way isn't
it good yeah Missy about my mask optics
there we go ah okay so what I am
supposed to go this way I suppose hmm
yeah huh I jump on you okay so that's
not happening maybe I could move this
one over there avoid these crazy water
monsters hmm I am NOT going the right
way am i yeah there seems to be a route
let's go no invisible wall can't even go
that way nope can't go that way either
what am i doing what am i doing
seriously what am i doing I'm screwing
up that's what I'm doing I can't even
see a way to get up
um okay so I'm gonna go back now
apparently flew deep and I'm gonna go
another way everyone ignore this I did
not just fail I did not just do a
spectacular belly flop into the into the
levels of mediocrity I am actually
skilled assassin and I did not go
outside where I wasn't supposed to go
you all did not see a thing
floow2 come on I said blood do blue deep
blue do flitter be flipping they do slip
bouche and and now blue fish
no okay blue Boosh
no all up there okay flip flip Boosh
blue TV there we go and now we're good
oh hello I'm not gonna risk that and
food yeah like powers
oh well no oh oh oh no oh
stay up here hahaha this would be
smarter hello rats you're right where I
need to be so I'm going to slow time and
go past you hello
ow ow ah balderdash I should have kept
the slow time well you all did not see a
thing
no one saw anything I did not fail we're
all good and I'm going to go up here
right now right now right now right now
ah ha ha oh yeah like a mouse yeah all
right now it's time for the
he says that's right me for a second I
thought he might even shake hands
uh-huh no quiet oh you are so going to
die you are going to die in so many ways
I hope really excruciating ly painful
ways one of those things that's with the
green
well what's with the blue oh hello so
anyway about you being dead feet are and
to dust that's awesome Piazza dice you
don't see a thing
no no you don't see a thing eh okay
that's not what I wanted to do but
alright I'll take it
hey meal of the deathy kill stabs wheel
of the murder murder deines seriously
what is with these green things
Oh items oh hello
alright then now finally we are alone in
the night with shadows in case I didn't
let you know I am like a shadow in the
night yes
don't look back
no no one is no one's supposed to be on
duty there yes oh how do I get through
there
Oh through this door maybe yes perfect
well I remember this this is where I
played hide and seek ooh
spring razor trap that's what it looks
like I don't use enough that I'll rewire
tools I don't know what that means
rude oh boy don't look at me don't look
at me I don't I still don't know how to
beat tall boys whatever I guess part one
is not letting them find you okay I can
climb up there I think I could probably
come on oh come on come on come on there
we go all right whoa whoa whoa whoa ah
come on
okay so so far so good
that guy's staring right at me oh all
right so if I buy Ward's over there who
no you didn't see a thing you did not
see a thing you didn't see anything
nope nope nope nope nope
well hello who's over here while having
a romantic night day hey hey Oh like a
mouse I told you get for bad-mouthing me
oh you didn't see a thing
question mark
and suspicions God all right so I don't
like those tallboys those are those guys
are
you don't see me I'm going to bend time
and then just go over here like a mouse
like a shadow in the extremely bright
lit area
oh god this is wrong this is wrong
there's nowhere don't debate oh no no no
oh no I messed up Jamie
somehow mysteriously did not see a thing
I don't know how but you did okay is
there a way can I just up over that
please please please oh who knows crap
crap oh crap crap oh crap
no no no no no no no no that's not how I
want to play okay
so I think it's best I start from back
here anyway OOP that guy didn't do you
think like a shadow in the night oh yeah
I gotta take care of that
suspicious couple ah crap
nope alright I'm gonna just murder
everyone I see how about that that
sounds like a good plan huh yeah yep
black shadow in the night I don't like
those tallboys
oh no no no what's that oh what's that
Oh your head mysteriously came off
what's that what happen to your head
there oh come on I'm gonna get this
fudge nut errs alright fine mathematics
based music did it say you're gonna get
your head to toe
I don't have a problem with that okay
did you see a thing Oh what the answer
is No
damn straight fudge what what oh come on
what is that that is that all right who
is hard all right so that guy's going to
sleep and not dying
cuz somehow he was able to be seen I
don't know I don't know
no one saw a thing right oh I get it
that towers like flipping pass
damn this is tough
all right
yeah you too nope that's what I thought
okay like a shadow in the night stalking
from the darkness bla bla bla bla bla
no I'm good and no one suspect something
alright now I just got to figure out a
way to get over oh come on how do you
see me through a bush I'm guessing in
this game bushes aren't exactly hiding
material all right let me see something
damn it this is a mistake how is it
mistake now it's a mistake I'm not doing
so good alright just got to get in here
I'm just gonna get in and that's all
that there is to it I want to get in and
then I'm gonna get out
indeed I believe so we should gather for
whiskey and cigars crap
okay there has got to be a way to get
around this guy without him spotting
these like I've got to be able to get up
here
and they're fine good good good good
good good
oh you come back here that's a mistake
okay I see
ah bonds nutters or I'll take care of
that guy first and then I'll take care
of you
get out right now
damnit
duh how bad can I be ah all right I'm
gonna get this gonna get this cuz I'm
not a bad flare how about that is that
better
does that work for you alright there we
are
we're good we're good we are good I'm
gonna look for something that I
shouldn't look for a long time boo Arun
I want that rude but it's outside the
gate now fine forget it forget it
all right so now finally we are inside
ruin their ruin there all right what is
that no door oh he's our doors
everything is secure on the grounds Lord
Regent
to check again I'm going to head down
over tied to my bedroom begging your
pardon sir mm-hmm what no no no no no I
need the comfort of my own bed tonight
uh-huh
sure you do the tower security top of
the guard if you have to come see me
before you finish your rounds
okay paranoid douche as you wish origins
all right so we've got those guys there
so I got it I got to be able to get to
the Lord Regent because he's in his own
bedroom tonight but I got to be able to
get to him without arousing suspicion
and I went to a bad place didn't nope
nothing's ridiculous dunwall tower
skeleton key I didn't know I got that
haha yeah
whoo come on that was awesome that was
like the greatest thing I've ever seen
in my entire life I have to keep playing
from that that is amazing ah crap crap
crap crap crap crap crap this guy Joseph
sleeping aw crap whoops well that makes
more sense because he's actually alive
or dead not alive
just chill accent out no a mine this guy
he's fine he's perfectly fine yeah
nothing to worry about
he's fine all right so now he just blew
himself up with whale oil all right so
anyway I'm saving from that that was
awesome that was like mega ultra awesome
okay
gotta get there gotta get broadcast
control station got to get tortured
chamber torture where's chamber why why
do I need to go to torture chamber all
right I'm killing this guy hello
what oh come on
no God died gosh darn it okay that's not
an option
darn it gosh darn it what
nope thousand now's not it oh no not
good not good not stupid that was stupid
on multiple levels alright so I'm just
gonna sneak past him
like a shadow in the frickin night like
a frickin shadow in the frickin night
okay so that lady's going to the torture
room maybe I can get this I've been
hearing strange noise oh yeah where are
they coming from the torturers Rose he's
a walking freak show yeah let's stay
clear of it everyone does uh-huh okay
wrong with he's mute but it's more than
uh huh
I heard the overseers were furious
because they suspect him of practicing
the dark arts baby boo is there anyone
get up I feel weird being on the ground
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap feds
notice okay
I'm doing poorly here I've been hearing
strange noises from the end of the
hallway
I like how the bodies just disappear
like that that is very helpful all right
so I'm actually upstairs this is the way
to the Lord Regents room but the
broadcasting tower is all there so I
gotta figure this you told her oh oh oh
no like a shadow in the night like a
shadow in the night
[Music]
okay now we're clear all right all right
not bad not bad at all okay so you need
to go unconscious thank you very much
all right that's one down
why is my reticle red is someone on to
me shouldn't be not these guys anyway
narcs
[Music]
well there we are
finally God I did it all right this is
how I'm playing not totally crappily I'm
actually gonna be good and skillful and
totally like a boss who a chamber pot no
that's not leaky water pot why would I
be excited for a chamber pot anyway what
is wrong with me
I don't know okay I'm going to the
torturers room like oh wow okay so I
just go down here I don't even know why
I need to go down here but I'm going
down
that doesn't look kill the torture oh
okay
easy enough nah it's too easy
there's got to be a bit more personal
than that
wait that guy's dead why is he why is he
mutilating that corpse and you didn't
see anything buddy one second
come on calm down there no one's here
that's right that's what I thought oh
[Music]
come on
ah [ __ ] no no come on all right
like I said gonna play skillfully and
awesomely no that's not the case
absolutely not the case
all right so take two and I'm going to
do this correctly
and here we go dad
nice thank you and thank you for the
rune I am the high walls if your enemy's
stronghold yes indeed what an impressive
sight we make on the way to face the
Lord Regent aha how will you end his
reign by blood or by truth yeah it's not
an easy man to get close to
AHA if the Empress had been as well
guarded how different things would be
now yeah is it just energy or after or
do you have another plan in mind
uh-huh will you restore things make it
alright again and crown a new Empress I
like that plan anyway I expect a good
show
I'll give you a good show you know
you're the only one that I actually
trust in all this and only because
you're trustworthy because I don't trust
you if that even makes a little bit of
sense what the hell what ah I don't come
from no oh God we're in a friggin dog
hyena thing come from
no get out of here what the hell
wolf hound ah what done all rats okay
anyway so Oh ready then okay what
getting kind of freaky anyway I'm all
out of time so thank you all so much for
watching hope you enjoyed it click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye